are you ready for the trip of a lifetime
because this not so little machine
is about to take you on one a trip
back in time what would you need for
this
time travel to happen how would it mess
with your body
and what do black holes have to do with
all this
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you built a tipler time machine
theoretically building a time traveling
device is
possible or almost possible
all you'd need to do is to assemble an
enormous cylinder
and get yourself a spaceship then you'd
need to figure out how to make the
cylinder spin at a few billion rotations
per minute
and remember when i said it was enormous
well for this cylinder to work its
length
would need to be infinite
before i get into the explanation of how
this time machine
works let me give you a bit of a
backstory
in 1915 albert einstein came up with his
theory of general relativity
he claimed that our universe can be
described by four dimensions
the first three would be the dimensions
of space
and the fourth would be time
together there's space-time
gravity can bend space-time like a
bowling ball would bend a rubber sheet
the bending of space-time makes time
[Music]
the passage of time also changes
depending on how fast you move
the theory of general relativity blew
people's minds but
in 1974 frank tipler realized that
solutions to equations of general
relativity
could be used to build a time traveling
device
[Music]
now that you're all caught up let's
start building this machine already
first you'd need to find material with
the total mass
of about 10 suns
[Music]
where you'd find all that matter is a
big question of course but
let's assume you managed to strip all
the neighboring star systems
and assemble them into a cylinder
somewhere above the earth
10 solar masses worth of matter is no
joke
it would take up a lot of space and you
would have to figure out how to compress
all that matter
it would have to be so dense that it
would turn into an
elongated black hole there's no time to
worry about getting sucked into it
now that you finally assembled a tipler
cylinder
you'd need to make it rotate at an
unimaginably fast rate
a few billion times every minute
theoretically instead of condensing a
whole lot of matter into a black hole
and then having to deal with the
cylinder rotation you
could just find a few neutron stars
those are leftovers from gigantic stars
that
didn't have enough mass to collapse into
black holes and
they rotate pretty fast you could line a
few of them up and synchronize their
rotation
but even if you chose the fastest ones
their rotation wouldn't come close to a
few billion times per minute
besides uh we did an earlier video about
trying to
bring a spoonful of neutron star back to
earth and
it didn't go that well
anyway regardless of how you achieve
this effect
the massive gravitational pull of the
cylinder
combined with the fast rotation would
create a frame dragging effect
in other words the cylinder would drag
space-time
along with it that means that you could
hop on a spacecraft and follow the
spiral course of the cylinder
and that would take you back in time
time would fold upon itself and you'd
find yourself
in a closed time-like curve it's
a loop in which you're traveling into
the past has
always been a part of that past so you
wouldn't create any time paradoxes
if you change the direction of your
travel you'd go back to the future
or rather back to the time you started
your journey from
the tipler cylinder specialty is travel
into the past
not the future but hey you could hang
out with your favorite people from the
past
go see a real life jurassic world you
could even go back to the time
when the earth didn't have any life at
all
but of course there is a drawback all
that would
only be possible if the tipler cylinder
had an
infinite length it would have to go on
forever but that's just impossible
you can't build something that has no
end at all
if you tried to make a finite cylinder
then you'd have to deal with
some exotic matter and it's negative
energy
but we haven't discovered it yet and it
doesn't look like we'll be getting our
hands on this kind of matter anytime
soon i haven't even mentioned the
effects
of the black hole on your body you'd
instantly get sucked into the cylinder's
black hole if you got close enough
but hopefully there are other ways that
would allow you to travel through time
and when you do we'll be there for you
and help you survive this kind of trip
on our new show how to survive
you